welcome back to las vegas now it's time
to talk about our health
and how we can keep an extra eye on it
rocky is joining us in studio for more
hey rocky
hey mercedes and jc did you know that
there's a significant connection
between covet 19 and type 2 diabetes
help your diabetes the sponsor of this
segment is a company that can help you
reverse the risk
and stop your diabetes take a look dr
hockey is welcome to las vegas now
it's great to be here thanks of course
now you are the founder of help your
diabetes so
let's just start with what the
connection is between
type 2 diabetes and what we're all
dealing with right now covet 19.
yeah well the cdc says that 94
of anybody who dies from covid has at
least one underlying health condition
and one of the most common underlying
health conditions is type 2 diabetes
so it's really important for people who
have type 2 diabetes that try to reverse
it
so it can prevent them from having a
severe complication from cold but even
if they've got the vaccine by the way
now some people might not know that type
2 diabetes is reversible so
let's explain that yeah it's 100
reversible
we have the only patented system in the
world that reverses type 2 diabetes
and we actually guarantee results so
people follow our program if there's if
they're not
off all their diabetic meds at the end
they get 100
refund plus 500 just for trying it
so yeah it can definitely be reversed
when you change your lifestyle the right
way
that is incredible and i understand you
have a testimonial you want to share who
are we who are you
so this is uh paul martin's he's had a
great success
this is one of the thousands of people
who've gone through a program
so he's gonna kind of share his success
story i've been a diabetic
at least 12 or 13 years i was injecting
myself with basal insulin
levomir at between 20 and 40 units a day
i was taking 500 milligrams
of metformin twice a day
approximately four months later i was
off all of my medication
off of the basal insulin off of the
metformin
my blood sugar numbers had dropped they
have consistently
stayed right around the 100 level
my a1c measurement of
blood sugar when i started was around
7.5 or 7.6 when it was last
measured it was at 5.6
which is no longer
diabetic and so it's been able to be
reversed
under the help your diabetes program how
do people find more information
about the program yeah so right now they
can actually register for a
comprehensive
diabetes reversal consultation with me
so
that includes a diabetes reversal
training video presentation
they get a diabetes score and a
comprehensive diabetes assessment and a
plan
and so the normal fee for those 150
dollars the first 30 people that go to
the website actually get it for 37
only so you can go to stop your
stopyourdiabetesnow.com
that's stopyourdiabetesnow.com they can
register there
wow thank you so much dr hawkins this is
amazing work that you're doing
thank you to help your diabetes for
sponsoring this segment visit stop your
stopyourdiabetesnow.com
and check out their special offer a
comprehensive diabetes reversal
consultation